i've talked a lot about what fractional
reserve banking is
fractional
reserve
banking but i have kind of reserved
making any commentary on it and that's
what i'm actually going to do in this
video so just as a bit of a review in
the whole banking playlist i started off
with a very simple example of where on
an island let's say you had all of the
gold on an island and you give it to me
for safekeeping so now i have this asset
called gold you draw it like this
gold and let's say it's 100 gold pieces
that you gave me 100
gold and i also have a liability so this
is my primitive island bank and my
liability is that you could demand this
gold from me from whenever you want so
this is my liability
if i were to draw your balance sheet
this would be your asset so this would
be a you know an iou
iou 2 depositor
to depositor
so at any point in time i've told you
look i have this nice safe this vault
here but you can come up to me anytime
and take as much of your gold as you
want and we of course know from the
fractional reserve banking playlist that
there's a slight discrepancy between
what i told you the depositor and the
reality of the situation because the
first thing that i'm going to do when
you take this is you know i've i've
taken your deposits and i could charge
you for keeping your money with me but
i've come up with a a slightly sneakier
scheme
slightly sneakier scheme where i say hey
i've seen your behavior you never
withdraw more than 10 gold pieces out at
a time so what i do is i lend out all
but 10 of your gold pieces
so we end up with this situation
10 gold pieces
you
i have an iou to you of 100 gold pieces
right like that
gold iou and i take the other 90 gold
pieces and i lend it out to random
entrepreneurs on our island
i lend it out to
these are loans to random entrepreneurs
so loan
to a and that is loan
to b and i think this is great because i
obviously collect interest from these
guys and assuming that these guys don't
blow the money i'll get all the money
back so you'll get all your money back
and i'll get some interest and i can say
hey i'm keeping your money for free you
get safekeeping and i collect the
interest on it and maybe that helps you
know to fund making the vault nice and
everyone's happy but clearly here
there's there is a discrepancy what did
i tell you
what did i tell you the depositor
so what did i tell you
i told you that you can withdraw 100
gold pieces at any time
you can withdraw
100 gold pieces at any time
any time
now what is the reality
what is the reality
the reality is you can withdraw
gold pieces 10 gold pieces
at any time
and clearly this is you know
you know i don't know if you want to
call this a lie or not but this isn't
completely true right here
and i know some of you know you might be
saying hey sal but isn't this you know
this is kind of a very primitive example
with gold pieces but our current banking
system doesn't work quite like this and
let's just to make the make sure that
the you you understand that the analogy
isn't completely off from our current
banking system the current banking
system is more like this
you have 10 gold pieces that you give me
you have 10 gold pieces i'll draw it
here this is this is the modern right
here the modern
banking system
and what you do is you give me a deposit
of 10 gold pieces like that
10 gold pieces and so i say that yeah
sure
i owe you
10 gold pieces so this is my iou to you
everything looks nice and and clean
right now but what i then do is then i
issue checking deposits to other people
and
my limit on how many checking deposits i
can issue is based on the reserve
requirements and all of that but let's
say i can let i have to keep at least 10
reserves just to keep the math simple so
what i do in our modern system is i make
a loan to b
i make a loan to b
loan to b like that and i give b a
checking account i give b
a checking account that is equivalent to
your checking account so this is an iou
to b
i owe you to b so this is essentially a
promise to be that look this is a
checking account at any time you can
come and get this much you know maybe
this was maybe this was
40 and maybe this is 50 gold pieces this
means that you can come at any time and
get 40 gold pieces from me but we know
the reality that people actually don't
actually get the gold pieces and in our
modern system we're not even dealing
with gold this will be reserved currency
but it's the same idea that people are
are getting money that really isn't
necessarily in the reserves and of
course i'm going to make another loan to
person a
i'm going to make another loan to person
a
and i'm just going to create a checking
account deposit for them
i'm just going to create another
checking and iou to a for 50. and the
whole reason why this works is because
people use people use these checking
account deposits as a form of money
when i write you a check
notice what's happening i'm just
transferring one of these checking
account deposits i'm just transferring
some of these rights from me to you
without any gold or without any reserve
currency actually changing hand so
that's how it works but if you look at
these two balance sheets one is kind of
the primitive example on my island where
i had 100 gold pieces and i lent out 90.
i owe a hundred i've told people maybe
it's just one person that lay you can
come to me at any time and get your 100
gold pieces but the reality is i've lent
all but 10 of it out to other people now
what's the situation in the modern well
i have i've told people that there's a
hundred gold pieces they can come from
me right 10 to the original depositor 40
to this guy that i gave a loan to and
another 50 to that guy but the reality
is is that i only have 10 gold pieces in
my vault and my other assets are just
loans to people so if you look at these
two balance sheets
you see that they are
equivalent and i always like to start
with this one because this one at least
makes more sense if you were to just you
know walk up to a five-year-old and say
look this is what fractional reserve
banking is this one
starts to seem even a little bit even
shadier because you're creating these
loans and you're creating these ious out
of thin air but their end result is that
they're equally shady because they both
have the same resulting balance sheet so
your next question is hey sal well you
know what's wrong with this and i think
you could ask you know i could ask my
son once he learns to talk what's wrong
with this is that there's a discrepancy
between what i told
what i told the depositor so in this
case i told the deposit you can withdraw
100 gold pieces any time when the
reality is they can withdraw 10 here i'm
telling the depositor
here you can i'm telling the depositor
you can take your money whenever demand
money whenever
whatever where the reality in this
modern system is that you can demand
whenever and i would throw an asterisk
there
as long as
as long
as no more than 10 percent
no more
than
10 percent
ask for the money at the same time
ask for money
at
the same
time
now you know obviously i think this is
it everyone already becomes a little
uncomfortable when you say this but you
say look you know this is what our
modern financial system is based on and
what this allows is this guy this bank
however you want to view it is allowed
to be an intermediary between the savers
the people who are giving their deposits
and the people who need to invest the
capital in in building new projects and
whatever else and the counter argument
to that for someone who's against
fractional rankings there's nothing to
stop you from doing this all you have to
do is tell this guy the truth what you
do is you do this exact same situ
scenario but you don't tell this guy you
can withdraw
you don't tell them you can withdraw 100
gold pieces at any time
you tell them you can withdraw
and that the other and that maybe there
are another 40 gold pieces will be
available
in whenever this guy is supposed to pay
back his loan maybe in a year
and that the other 50 gold pieces
would be
available
in whenever this guy pays his loan back
maybe it's in two years
so the question is why doesn't this
happen well the reality is is because if
you told if you told the depositor this
if you told the depositor that they
can't have all of their money on demand
he'd say okay fine
one assuming that you're giving these
guys you know these are legitimate
people to give your money to i want some
of the interest that you're taking
because you're just lending out my money
so this if you were to lock up your
money for longer right this money is
being
locked up
locked up people would want interest for
this but when the bank is allowed to
kind of tell this half truth they don't
have to give as much interest on it
because when people say oh i can get my
money whenever i want they say well then
i don't need that much interest on it
because it's on demand but the reality
is they can't get all of their money at
any time they can only get some fraction
some fraction of their money at any time
so the next thought might be okay you're
being a little bit disingenuous when you
tell the depositor that it's on demand
and because you're being disingenuous
you're allowed to kind of not give them
as much interest as you would have to
give them if you told them that your
money is locked up well what's wrong as
long as you are a good investor and that
you put these you put this money to good
use doesn't the whole world benefit and
that might be true most of the time
assuming everything i just told you but
imagine a situation where we have
multiple banks in our universe
we have multiple banks so let me draw my
multiple banks so this is bank
bank one i have bank
bank two and then bank
three and bank one and bank two are very
honest and good investors
good investors and we all know it's very
hard to see know who's a good or a bad
investor is especially when times are
good because don't then most loans tend
to come out good so they're good
investors
but bank three takes on extra risk
let me write it down extra risk
and what's their incentive for taking
extra risk let's say that bank three is
willing to lend to people that banks one
and two wasn't weren't willing to lend
to so bank three's balance sheet here
these loans are going to be riskier
loans now why would they do that
because when you give it to riskier
people you're able to take more interest
from them
so they take extra risk which leads to
extra interest from their extra interest
and actually if you were to look at
these banks you would say that this guy
is more the most profitable bank
the most profitable
most profitable
even worse because he's getting extra
interest he can actually share more of
that extra interest with their
depositors so you you can give higher
higher yielding checking accounts i
guess i could call it
higher
interest
on
deposits
so in this situation the person who's
taking the the most risk is going to be
the most profitable and and they're
going to give the higher interest and
they might actually attract the most
deposits right if i could find if all of
these guys look the same to me and we
all know it's very hard to know what
banks are actually doing with their
money then i'll say hey i'm going to
give my money to this guy right over
there but then what happens as soon as
things go bad as soon as the world gets
a little bit difficult this extra risk
actually starts rearing its ugly head
and then this guy becomes insolvent so
this guy's let me see if i can draw his
balance sheet his balance sheet will
look something like this
he has a bunch of
loans out he's got some reserves right
there and then he's got a bunch of
deposits
that you or i might have given him
these are our iou's to us these are his
loans out as soon as things start going
bad some of these loans are going to go
bad as soon as one of those loans go bad
i'm going to hear it about on i'm going
to hear about it on the news and i'm
just i'm going to run over to the bank
and i'm going to say let me get my money
back as quickly as possible and i let's
say i'm the first one there and i get my
money back they promised it to me
so i
so i would draw my account right there
and i get all my money back and i
essentially deplete the reserves now the
next guy is going to come along this guy
was a little bit of a slower runner than
me he comes to the bank he says give me
back my reserves and the bank says there
are no reserves and then this guy is mad
he has no reserves and of course the
whole time this guy's this bank's assets
are just becoming worthless because he
loaned it to people who invested it
badly and so you have all of these
people when he finds out that this guy
didn't get his money all of these people
are going to go there and demand their
money and the bank is going to be
insolvent
well it's going to be two things it's
going to be illiquid and insolvent and
i've explained the difference but a
liquid might mean it might have the
loans might be good and actually i'll
explain it i'll reiterate it in this
video but the loans might be good it
just doesn't have the cash insolvent
means that these loans aren't even good
at the value of these loans aren't equal
to these deposits so i'll say that this
risky bank is insolvent
is insolvent now that you might say
these guys right here deserve it
these guys deserve what they got because
they were greedy they invested in this
risky bank that was doing shady things
just to get a little bit higher interest
on their deposits but what happens when
this happens
well you have these good banks over here
these good banks over here that maybe
did really conservative lending
they did really conservative lending so
this is what their balance is maybe both
of their balance sheets look like this
they have some reserves
right there and then they've made out
some good loans to to good to good
entrepreneurs and then you have their
depositors
these are their depositors right there
but as soon as this guy
finds out about what happened at that
bank he's like things are really bad let
me just be careful and go to my bank
let's say it's this depositor right here
and take my money out and put it into my
mattress so he goes to the bank and he's
the first one there he's the fastest
runner of all of the depositors so he
claims his deposit so his deposit he
withdraws and he depletes all of the
reserves
he depletes all the reserves now he
wasn't the only guy who was afraid this
guy was afraid as well so he comes
running to the bank and the bank now
says you know gee i know i promised you
i know i made this promise to you that
you have an on-demand account
but that guy you lease all leaving the
bank with the running shoes on he
actually just took all of the reserves
and i i guess i have to admit now that i
lied to you that it isn't completely on
demand i actually loaned out the rest of
your money but i was a good banker you
know i these are actually good loans
these loans are still worth what they
want if you just wait long enough you'll
get your money back and of course this
guy is going to be not so happy because
he would lie to and that's not going to
be the only guy there's slightly slower
runners are going to come there and also
demand their money and this is known as
a bank run
this is a bank run
where because one maybe bad apple in the
system actually did is insolvent
everyone becomes afraid and comes and
says give me my money and because we
have this fractional reserve system the
money isn't there it just will not be
there because 90 of it is lent out and
so once this happens here then you're
gonna have a run on bank two and then
everyone everyone is going to take their
money out of the banking system so the
whole banking system this situation
right here where the assets
maybe still are worth the same or more
than the liabilities this guy is still
solvent but he doesn't have any money to
pay these on-demand accounts so this guy
is this guy is running into a liquidity
problem
liquidity problem he doesn't have the
reserves and that's why we have the
whole f we have the whole federal
reserve that's a lender of last resort
this guy can go walk to the federal
reserve and say hey i have some people
knocking on my door give me some loans
the federal reserve will lend this guy
we'll lend this guy some money and of
course then this guy is going to have
another depositor called or another
lender to it called the federal reserve
and he can use this to pay off these
guys but that leaves another question
how does the federal reserve really know
the difference between this guy you
might say okay this guy's good let me
just lend to him to make sure that he
doesn't have a liquidity problem how
does the federal reserve really know the
difference between this guy and this guy
right here this guy's going to also run
to the federal reserve hey you know
federal reserve these loans are still
good just give me a loan so i can pay
these people right there so the federal
reserve says hey you look good you
you're a nice clean banker in a nice
fancy building wearing have you have a
rolex on your arm you must be good for
it so the federal reserve will also lend
this guy and now this guy also owes the
federal reserve
some money you can already see that in
this fractional reserve banking system
you have two problems you have an
unstable equilibrium
unstable
equilibrium where one bad apple can lead
to a run on the entire system
one bad bank
bad bank
leads to a run on the entire system
entire system and i'll talk about what's
been engineered to fix this problem
essentially uh banking insurance i'll
probably wait for that to the next video
so this is the first problem right here
and then the second problem
is that it it really becomes hard to
differentiate between the good and bad
banks
hard
to
differentiate
i mean it's not so hard to differentiate
at face well it is hard to differentiate
at first it becomes even harder
differentiate when you always have the
federal reserve be willing to be a
lender of last resort and when i talk
about the federal reserve insurance that
makes it even harder to differentiate
because it's hard to differentiate
there's a huge incentive for banks to
take on risk because when times are good
they'll make more money than everyone
else and then when times are bad when
times are bad it's really hard that
they'll all suffer equally so in the
next video i'll talk about some of what
has been engineered to fix these
problems and see if they actually make
sense